So much for keeping secrets.
Ever since they witnessed half of their favorite
superheroes disintegrate in Avengers: Infinity
War, Marvel fans have been on their edge of
their seats wondering how things will turn
out in the fourth Avengers movie.
After what felt like an eternity, Marvel Studios
released the movie's first trailer in December
2018, revealing the title of the film to be
Avengers: Endgame.
But when the studio dropped the footage, it
also broke a few hearts — the first look
at the film was hardly a triumphant one.
The teaser showed Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony
Stark floating aimlessly through space, low
on food and oxygen, and seemingly preparing
to die.
Instead of rallying for a vengeful strike
against Thanos, his nemesis, the only glimpse
we saw of Iron Man was him recording a farewell
message to fiancée Pepper Potts.
While some began preparing to say goodbye
to the billionaire bad boy, others started
speculating that another hero would swoop
in to save Tony from the brink of certain
death.
One theory assembled evidence that Pepper
herself would do the saving, by finally assuming
her comic book alter ego of Rescue to somehow
bring her beau back home.
"Just for the record Being adrift with no
hope of rescue is more fun than it sounds."
But a recent announcement from the car company
Audi may have inadvertently spoiled who will
actually save Tony's life in Endgame.
During a presentation at January 2019's Consumer
Electronics Show, Audi announced that it had
partnered with Marvel to develop a VR experience
that ties in with Endgame.
The cross-promotion will allow fans to venture
through space from the backseat of Audi's
e-tron Vision Gran Turismo.
The vehicle will be making an appearance in
Endgame, supposedly with an alive-and-well
Tony Stark behind the wheel.
"Well you have driven it already?”
"Yeah, well as Tony Stark on Avengers 4"
This development seemed to confirm that Tony
will make his way back to Earth in the fourth
Avengers adventure, and in good enough condition
to feel like zipping around in a sweet luxury
two-seater.
The idea that Tony will survive his jaunt
through space, if true, barely feels like
a spoiler.
It never seemed likely that he'd actually
die out there.
But an important question remained: who would
be the one to rescue him?
Aspects of Audi's promotion strongly suggest
that the hero who saves Tony might be none
other than Rocket Raccoon — which would
surely come as a hallucinatory experience
for the oxygen-starved, dehydrated Earthling.
The details are all in the title of Audi's
VR experience, "Marvel's Avengers: Rocket's
Rescue Run."
The game will apparently have players slide
into the e-tron GT's backseat, where they'll
control another vehicle as though they were
Rocket on a space-faring rescue mission.
Though the name of the game alone doesn't
specify who Rocket is rescuing, it certainly
implies that Rocket might be the one who comes
to Tony's aid.
Tony is in Rocket's spaceship, after all — and
at the start of Avengers: Endgame, it would
appear that he'll need rescuing more than
anyone else.
Well, as long as we're not counting the people
who got dusted.
Did Audi really release promotional details
that spoil this aspect of Endgame?
Thanks to an in-depth account of "Rescue Run"
from The Verge writer Sean O'Kane, it appears
pretty likely that that's exactly what's happened.
In a piece published on January 7th, just
ahead of Audi's presentation at CES, O'Kane
wrote,
"Iron Man needs help.
He's being chased through outer space by some
of Thanos' baddies, so Rocket Raccoon and
I rush to his aid.
We make a few jumps using the Universal Neural
Teleportation Network, and a few rollicking
minutes later, I've helped blast the enemies
to bits."
Small leaks about potential plot details happen
all the time with movies this high-profile,
but it's pretty wild to think that the famously
unforthcoming Marvel might have let this spoiler
slip.
It's possible that the studio could have revealed
this info as a fakeout, as they've done before,
putting out misleading information to muddy
the waters when it comes to actual leaks.
On the flip side, it's also possible that
this reveal is genuinely a marketing miscalculation
that reveals too much too soon.
Both possibilities seem equally likely, and
are sure to fuel online debate as the movie's
much-anticipated release draws closer.
As things stand now, there's a solid chance
that Endgame will see the galaxy's most beloved
trash panda head to space, save Tony, and
haul him back to Earth to reunite with the
other surviving heroes.
Then they can formulate a plan to take down
Thanos, revive the fallen heroes, and then
take a joy ride in his cool new whip to celebrate
a job well done.
I cannot believe it I haven’t driven one of these
in a while."
So — does this theory hold water?
From a story standpoint, Rocket saving Tony
would make a lot of sense.
The Endgame trailer revealed that Tony and
Nebula will escape Titan onboard the Benatar,
the ship Star-Lord commandeered.
The last time we saw Rocket, he was stranded
on Earth in Wakanda, watching helplessly as
several heroes, including his best buddy Groot,
fell away to nothingness.
He's the only Guardian to have made it out
of Thanos' decimation with his life intact,
but at the end of Infinity War, he has no
way of knowing that.
So it's reasonable that Rocket will start
off Endgame fiercely determined to locate
his missing teammates — and where else would
he start looking for them than their own spaceship?
As plausible as all this sounds, right now
it's only a theory, and no one outside of
Marvel knows for sure how Tony will make it
back home.
We'll keep our eye on the developments, but
the only way to be sure what really happens
will be to wait patiently for the movie's
premiere on April 26th.
What's your secret?
Mellow jazz?
Bongo drums?
Huge bag?"